Michelle is in Phoenix hi Michelle
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up okay so I made a mistake of mixing
family with business so now I have a
little bit of a mess so about six and a
half years ago my dad co-signed on a car
for me in my now husband and we ended up
getting in an accident after it was paid
off and we paid all the deductibles and
everything we needed to do for that but
my dad's come back to me saying that he
lost his good driver bonus due to the
accident so he's asking me for $50 a
month to cover the good driver bones
that he lost I'm sorry how would he lose
his good driver bonus the car should
have been in your name was it no it
wasn't he co-signed for the loan and
therefore they told him he had to put
the the car under his insurance yeah
because the loan was in his name okay
Patel tell him that it's not a good idea
to co-sign and that this is the cost of
having co-signed just tell him that yeah
that's absurd okay what kind of toxic
relationship you got with your dad
that's just why you know my dad we
normally have a great relationship but
stuff like this whenever money's
involved it just makes it a business
relationship and I hate it because well
it's not even a business relationship if
this was a business transaction I tell
him stick it in his ear but since it's
your father and since it's your father I
would tell him something a little nicer
but I mean dude you signed up for the
trip it's called spin stupid and
co-signing and you got in you got
himself into a mess you both were stupid
for co-signing I've been stupid I've
co-signed I know what it looks like
every time I cosign alone I ended up
paying it one guy co-signed for me and I
went bankrupt he ended up paying it had
to go back and pay him and his wife
still mad at me and that was 30 years
ago so that's just for the car I guess
yeah you paid for the car he didn't get
stuck with a bill or anything like that
this is not you know he wants his good
driver bonus good luck
that's just toxic garbage no I mean
that does that it's just weird so no
just say dad I love you but you just
this is over the pale you're just asking
too much and no we're not gonna do that
and if you won't be mad about fifty
bucks you can be mad about fifty bucks
you signed up for this trip and you
shouldn't have I signed up for this trip
and I shouldn't have it was a bad deal
all the way around everyone that was in
this deal got harmed because we were
stupid and we shouldn't have done this
deal I'm really sorry you got harmed I
didn't set out to harm you but you know
all the bills were paid and you know if
you probably ought to look at changing
insurance companies if they cannot give
you your good driver discount it's
probably Allstate he probably needs to
shop his rates anyway it's probably high
so it sounds like to me but what do I
know
Wow amazing absolutely amazing this is
the Dave Ramsey show it's common sense
for your dollars and cents by the way
I'm not I'm quoting the Bible when I
said your co-signing is stupid it's in
Proverbs 1718 if you look it up in the
contemporary English version the CEV
version that says one hour who cosines
for another stupid and if you don't like
that version you can look it up in the
oh I mean in the New King James and it
says one lacking and since I'm sure
queue for another so every time you
cosign by definition biblically you're
stupid and I've been stupid biblically
speaking because I've cosign I just
recommend you never do it get yourself
and all these kinds of problems don't do
it never cosign ever ever ever never
ever cosign this is the Dave Ramsey show